- [Narrator] Acid rain
sounds like something
straight out of a sci-fi film,
like strange raindrops that fall in a city
and corrode everything.
The truth is not far off,
but the good news is that we know a lot
about what causes acid rain
and how to address its
impact on the environment,
our bodies and the built world.
Interestingly, normal rain
is actually slightly acidic as well.
If you think back to the pH scale,
you'll remember that it
goes from zero to 14,
acidic to basic,
and that seven, right in
the middle, is neutral.
Normal rain is around 5 or 5
1/2, so it's slightly acidic,
but acid rain is even more acidic
and typically around a pH of four.
Now this might not sound
like a big difference,
but remember that this
is a logarithmic scale.
So each increment, like from four to five,
is actually a tenfold difference.
So if we're comparing
normal rain, at about 5 1/2,
and acid rain at four,
that's a pretty big deal.
So now the questions are,
how does acid rain form?
Why does it matter?
And what effects can acid
rain have on our communities?
So the short answer to
how it forms is pollution.
So let me try to bring
that to life for you
with my imaginary hand-drawn drawn city.
Now remember that most of the fuels
we burn to make energy
are from fossil fuels,
so that animal and plant matter
that has been in the ground
for millions of years.
And when we burn these fuels,
they tend to have remaining
traces of sulfur in them,
especially coal.
And both coal and oil burn
at such high temperatures
that they can cause nitrogen
and oxygen in the air
to form different compounds.
So imagine we have here an oil refinery
and a coal burning
plant, and a lot of cars.
A common byproduct of coal
burning plants or smelters
and other industrial facilities
is sulfur dioxide, SO2.
At the same time, high temperatures
from combustion engines
and oil refineries provide enough energy
to break apart nitrogen and
oxygen molecules in the air.
These molecules can then recombine
to form different nitrogen
oxides, like nitric oxide, NO,
and nitrogen dioxide, NO2.
Together, these are referred
to as nitrogen oxides,
which you can abbreviate by NOx.
So the same can be said
about sulfur dioxide.
That falls into the category
of sulfur oxide, SOx, or SOX.
So a fun way to remember the precursors
to acid rain are SOX and NOX.
Now these precursors belonging
to the SOX and NOX family
are hanging out up in the air.
When they interact with
UV radiation from the sun
and water molecules that
are also in the air,
they form different
vapors, these acid vapors,
sulfuric acid vapor, H2SO4,
and nitric acid vapor, HNO3.
And these acids are no joke.
Sulfuric acid is highly
corrosive. It can burn your skin.
The vapors can irritate
your respiratory tract.
And nitric acid is known to be used
in explosives and rocket launches.
And these are the acids
that make up the phenomenon of acid rain.
Over time, these smoke stacks
have actually gotten taller.
One example in the early 1970s,
when the EPA wanted to reduce emissions
from these coal burning
facilities and oil refineries
to control the air quality
around those communities.
What these facilities did was
build larger smoke stacks,
or taller smoke stacks,
so that those pollutants
would disperse and spread out
over a larger area and not
fall over the local community
as much or as fast.
Instead, what ended up happening
is that these pollutants
were carried by the wind
to communities and natural
environments downwind
of where they were being created,
up to 1,000 kilometers, or over 600 miles.
And when these acid
vapors cause acid rain,
it's not always rain like we think of
with water falling from the sky.
Acid rain is just a general term
and it really includes all
forms of precipitation,
like snow, fog, cloud vapor,
and dry deposition, like dust particles.
And also it can have different
combinations of these forms.
And now the other big question
is why does it matter, right?
How are we affected?
And also does that acid burn your skin,
a very logical thing
(laughs) to want to know.
So for cities, first of
all, acid rain is bad news
because it can damage
buildings and statues,
particularly those that
are made of limestone,
marble, and some metals.
Here in this photo is a gargoyle
from the Munich Town Hall,
which is almost unrecognizable
because of all the damage
it sustained from acid rain.
There's also been a lot
of studies over the years,
looking at the US Capitol
and a lot of the surfaces
there that are made of marble
and how they can strengthen them
to protect them from acid
rain before it's too late.
Now, if we go a little
deeper, acid rain can leach
or pull out heavy metals, like aluminum,
from the soil or rocks,
which can then be washed out to lakes,
and as you can imagine, can
lead to a lot of bad things
like contaminating drinking water
and harming aquatic ecosystems.
Many fish can't survive at a lower pH.
Acid rain also has impacts on
other natural environments,
especially because of how far it reaches.
Acid rain can damage and
weaken forests and trees
by stripping nutrients from the soil
and even damaging the waxy outer coat,
leaving them much more vulnerable
to losing more nutrients.
Now, when it comes to
humans, these acid vapors
and the different
precipitation that they create
are very harmful to
our respiratory system,
and especially those that have asthma.
And of course, I have
to answer the question,
does acid rain burn your skin?
The answer is no, it's
just not acidic enough.
Remember acid rain is around a pH of four
and for something to burn your skin,
it has to be much more acidic,
usually around a pH of one.
There is some good news
when it comes to acid rain.
In 1990, the EPA created
the Acid Rain Program
to help power plants reduce emissions.
In 2019, when they looked at
the levels compared to 1990,
they saw pretty great reductions,
a 94% reduction in sulfur dioxide
and an 86% reduction in nitric oxides.
Now this is in the United
States, but around the world,
acid rain is still a problem,
particularly nitrates getting into the air
from sources like fertilizer
and livestock feed.
And even though we've had
great reductions since 1990,
there is still some work to be done.
And one of the ways that we can improve
is by switching over to
cleaner burning fuels,
or we can use renewable energy sources
like solar power, wind
power, and hydro-power
that ultimately reduce our
dependence on coal and oil.
So now I hope you learned a
little bit about acid rain,
how it's made, the impacts it can have,
and I hope you don't lose any sleep
over it burning your skin.